IT'S TIME TO PLAY THE
NUANCED ROLES FOR WOMEN IN
ENTOURAGE.
THE MELISSA MCCARTHY ACTION
COMEDY SPY WHICH IS
HILARIOUS AND HAS A 95% ON
ROTTEN TOMATOES AND YOU
SHOULD GO SEE IT, RULED
THE BOX OFFICE THIS WEEKEND
RAKING IN $30 MILLION, AND
HANDILY TROUNCING THE JEREMY
PIVEN HAIR PLUG VEHICLE,
ENTOURAGE.
WHICH ONLY MANAGED TO
SQUEEZE 10 MILLION BUCKS OUT OF
ITS SUBHUMAN FAN BASE.
DREAM LARGE, FAIL LARGER.
I MEAN...
SO MEANWHILE ON FUNNY OR
DIE COMEDIAN GIL OZERI STAYED
UP FOR 54 HOURS WATCHING EVERY
EPISODE OF ENTOURAGE THIS
WEEKEND AND RIGHT BEFORE HE
WENT INSANE HE COUNTED HOW
MANY TIMES FEMALE CHARACTERS
TALK TO EACH OTHER DURING
EIGHT SEASONS OF THE SHOW.
IN GUYS, IN EIGHT SEASON,
THE TOTAL 8.5 TIMES.
8.5 TIMES.
8.5 TIMES THAT A WOMAN
WAS NOT JUST A PROP ON
ENTOURAGE.
>> WOW.
>>CHRIS: DOES ENTOURAGE HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH STRONG FEMALE
CHARACTERS? MAYHAPS.
WE SPENT FIVE MINUTES
COMBING THE ENTOURAGE IMDB
PAGE AND FOUND A PLETHORA OF
FULLY-FORMED ROLES FOR WOMEN
ALL THE WAY RANGING FROM MODEL
AND
GYM MODEL TO THE INCREDIBLY
NUANCED BIKINI GIRL.
SO I'M GONNA SHOW YOU AN
ACTOR FROM IMDB AND BASED ON THE
TASTEFUL PHOTOS IN WHICH NO
WAY OBJECTIFY THEM, YOU HAVE
TO GUESS WHICH OF THESE TWO
REAL CHARACTERS THEY
PORTRAYED IN THE ENTOURAGE
MOVIE BECAUSE [BLEEP] KNOWS
YOU DIDN'T GO SEE IT IN THE
THEATER.
FIRST ONE, THIS YOUNG ACTOR.
WAS SHE GIVEN THE ROLE OF A
LIFETIME AS RAVER MODEL OR
TOPLESS YACHT GIRL.
SHE HAS BEEN SHRUNK DOWN
TO THE HEAD OF A TOOTHBRUSH.
GODFREY.
>> TOPLESS YACHT GIRL.
>> LET'S FIND OUT.
>> YES, TOPLESS YACHT GIRL.
(APPLAUSE)
>> UNCREDITED.
>> THIS PHOTO SHOWS THAT
BOTOX ISN'T JUST FOR WOMEN,
LOOK IT, HE'S GETTING
>>CHRIS: OH, [BLEEP].
>> HIS FOREHEAD IS PERFECT.
>> WHY DOES KEVIN DILLON'S FACE
LOOK LIKE A V FOR VENDETTA MASK?
>> HOW ABOUT THIS NOT AT ALL
EXPLOITED ACTOR?
WAS SHE ASKED TO BRING GRAVITAS
TO THE ROLE OF THE SUSHI GIRL
OR YELLING LADY IN THE CAR?
JENNIFER.
>> THANK YOU.
I AM GOING TO GUESS YELLING
LADY IN THE CAR.
>> SHE DOESN'T REALLY
SEEM LIKE SHE'S YELLING
THERE. DO YOU FEEL LIKE
SHE'S GOING TO EMOTE IN THE
CAR?
>> OR SHE'S ONE OF THOSE GIRLS
THAT LAYS DOWN WITH SUSHI
ALL OVER HER BODY AND I
FEEL LIKE IN HOLLYWOOD,
SHE'S LIKE NOT ANOREXIC
ENOUGH FOR THAT ROLE.
SO I FEEL LIKE IN HOLLYWOOD
THAT WOULD BE LIKE OH, JUST
LET HER YELL, GROSS.
>> THE CORRECT ANSWER--
[BLEEP] HOLLYWOOD.
THE ANSWER IS THE SUSHI GIRL.
>> YOU THINK THERE WAS A
SCENE LATER WHEN ONE OF THE
GUYS WAS DUDE, SHE WAS HOT
BUT SHE KIND OF
SMELLED LIKE FISH.
>> HOW DO YOU THINK HER
AGENT BROKE THE NEWS TO HER
THAT SHE GOT THE PART OF SUSHI
GIRL?
>> DOES SHE HAVE AN AGENT OR A
RUSSIAN MOB BOYFRIEND?
>> YOU WANT MY GIRLFRIEND TO
LAY DOWN WITH SUSHI ALL OVER
THE PUSSY, HUH?
IS THAT WHAT YOU WANT?
EXTRA $1,000 TO SHOW SUSHI
PUSSY.
>> NEXT UP WAS SHE
RESPECTFULLY CAST AS GIRL
DANCING UNCREDITED ON BOB
SAGET'S GIRL NUMBER ONE?
THIS GIRL LOOKS LIKE SHE
WOULD HAVE CO-HOSTED
SINGLED OUT WITH ME.
>> BOB SAGET'S GIRL NUMBER
ONE.
>>CHRIS: I THINK YOU MIGHT BE
RIGHT.
THERE IT IS.
>> YES.
>> AND HER AGENT'S LIKE, "YOU
HAVE TO BE IN A BATHING SUIT."
"FOR A BEACH SCENE?"
"NO, YOU'RE IN A SNEAKER
STORE."